[Música]
en medio de un paisaje de touguen tiene
lugar una escena espectacular un viejo
aerogenerador vestigio de una época
pasada
es descolgado de su mástil para ser
restaurado
en la región hay decenas como este se
llaman aerogeneradores en el siglo XIX
fueron utilizados para bombear agua de
las aguas subterráneas y hoy algunos
Encuentran una segunda juventud
[Música]
El pequeño pueblo de Express
y un puñado de entusiastas ya han vuelto
a poner en marcha su antiguo
aerogenerador goyé por amor a su
herencia rural y un poco también por
fascinación por la mecánica de estas
extrañas máquinas
estátor rotor y mecanismo de orientación
Esos son los tres elementos
fundamentales del aerogenerador
el propósito del estator es dirigir el
aire hacia el rotor para que tenga la
mayor fuerza posible
la utilidad del mecanismo de orientación
es orientar permanentemente al
aerogenerador al viento Tan pronto como
gire orientará toda la turbina eólica
directamente hacia el viento
generador abasteció de agua al castillo
vecino durante casi un siglo abandonado
en la década de 1950 fue completamente
restaurado en 2005 si el agua de los
acuíferos vuelve a brotar como antes
también es gracias a la ciencia de Jean
Claude
este mecánico aeronáutico retirado ahora
dedica su vida a los aerogeneradores
boyé en su despacho todo está
minuciosamente referenciado postales
dibujos planos un caudal de información
que ha dado nueva vida al aerogenerador
trabajé 43 años en la aeronáutica cuando
miras un aerogenerador Bosé de frente
teníamos uno en efg que se estaba
oxidando parece la toma de aire de un
reactor moderno dije por qué no ocuparse
de un aerogenerador aprendí cómo
funciona su historia hice un inventario
de esas máquinas en tu en Francia y
algunas en el extranjero
origen de este invento una saga familiar
la de la familia goyé primero fue Ernest
boyé un fundidor de Campanas y
itinerante quien se instaló en la ciudad
de limón e inventó un nuevo sistema
mecánico impulsado por viento Tuvo tres
hijos que diversificaron la industria
familiar august se hizo cargo de la
producción de turbinas eólicas
fabricó cilindros hidráulicos en cuanto
a la mayor amd voye su nombre está
grabado en letras doradas en la historia
del automóvil
[Música]
en 1873 inventó el primer vehículo de
carretera a vapor equipado con dirección
descendiente de la familia boyé Ya
fallecido pasó gran parte de su vida
contando la epopeya de su familia
emblemática de la Revolución Industrial
del siglo 19 la exposición de París la
exposición Universal del centenario de
la Revolución los presentaron campanas
turbinas eólicas sistemas hidráulicos La
retirada de los carros de vapor y
calculadoras tenían cinco stands de
exposición es fabuloso
[Música]
nos reunimos con Jean Claude nuestro
salvador de turbinas eólicas cerca de
amboad la pista de un vestigio
particularmente notable
y aquí está el único aerogenerador
catalogado en el castillo de gavilier
construido en 1888 este aerogenerador
sufrió muchos daños sobre todo durante
la última Guerra Mundial ya que las
tropas alemanas que se encontraban Al
otro lado del loira disparaban contra
este Rincón de observación seguramente
hubo personas que observaron a esas
tropas y que se instalaron en la parte
superior de este aerogenerador lo que
explica que todavía encontremos impactos
de Gran calibre en él
y la pasión de Jean Claude ha sido
emulada en la región
en el pequeño pueblo de soriñí se
encuentra actualmente el más colorido de
los aerogeneradores el original había
sido destruido en la década de 1960 no
importa estos entusiastas fueron a
buscar otro para devolverle al pueblo
una parte de su patrimonio
todo lo hicieron los miembros de la
asociación todos ellos jóvenes jubilados
de profesiones diversas y
complementarias entonces un año y medio
después fue restaurado
hice muchas pinturas porque a los demás
no les gustaba mucho así que me quedé
con eso el aerogenerador que recuperamos
ya tenía las aspas pintadas entonces
pensamos que sería bueno devolverle el
aspecto que tenía antes por eso elegimos
los colores de arcoiris para pintar de
nuevo todas las aspas el desafío poner
una pieza de 500 kilos en un mástil de
15 metros de altura de trabajo de
precisión que concluye dos años de
restauración
[Música]
gracias a la pasión y al trabajo duro de
estos Guardianes del viento los
aerogeneradores de boyé no han dejado de
girar